well if you had a few days of
uninterrupted free time to do literally
whatever you wanted
how would you spend it we're not life
coaches we're just talk show host but we
do have a humble suggestion
you might want to consider listening to
barack obama talk about himself
in his second autobiography for 29
hours straight i mean that sounds a
little crazy
but listen to this sample from his new
audio book
and try to ask yourself are you not
irresistibly attracted to that idea
here it is she generally avoided talking
to me about the horse race aspects of
the campaign
which is why i was surprised when in bed
later that night
she turned to me and said you're gonna
win aren't you
a lot can still happen but yeah there's
a pretty good chance i will
i looked at my wife her face was pensive
as if she were working out a puzzle in
her mind
finally she nodded to herself and
returned my gaze
you're gonna win she said softly he
kissed me on the cheek
turned off the bedside lamp and pulled
the covers over her shoulders
wasn't he supposed to be a great writer
or they always tell you he's a great
writer really
too many adverbs too stilted
reads like a pg-13 version of a stacey
abrams softcore novel
which we strongly prefer adam crowell is
the host of the adam corolla show he has
some ideas about how you might spend 29
hours of free time
he joins us tonight hey adam how would
you spend 29 hours not that you ever
have it
well first off let me tell you how big
this book is
i downloaded it today and my
phone got heavier
just for the ones and zeros that's crazy
yes yes it's it's uh
i think it's 19 bucks at amazon but uh
shipping is 1700.
what look he's not that much older than
either one of us he was president i'll
give him that for two terms that's great
but two autobiographies before you're
60. i think we can say he doesn't have a
self-esteem problem
now you know as i was sort of thinking
about this subject i thought it's
interesting so
our current president everyone accuses
of being an insane narcissist so
everyone thinks he's an egomaniac
narcissist but the reality is is
obama is a bigger narcissist than trump
trump comes in a narcissist package
trump comes in a narcissist package you
can see from outer space
and um obama's kind of like a stealth
fighter jet but he's much more of a
narcissist than trump is and i know a
lot of people would go
how's that possible it is i believe that
if you took those guys
and you squeezed them and you got every
drop of narcissism
out of them that obama's beaker would be
much more full of narcissism than trump
it's a disgusting image it's interesting
though i mean
i wonder in the 29 hours does he
acknowledge
that his mismanagement division that he
caused within the country over eight
years
paved the way for trump does he ever
take credit for that i wonder
i don't know i was only able to listen
to the first
17 hours on the toilet this morning so i
haven't gotten to the rest of the book
okay are you clearing your schedule i
hope
yes i am the thing about obama
is nobody is better at saying
nothing than obama if there was a
hall of fame for people that delivered
no message but in a in a fantastic
package i think that's obama i think
that's right
but there was anger at the center of
that i think we're just starting to
figure out obama it's taking a while
he's not stupid i will say that adam
krull great to see you
thank you thanks ducker